Nadia Murad and Lamia [ __ ] Bashar thank
you very much first of all for doing
this um I have a question because I
assume you follow the news as well now
with the situation we have now in Iraq
and and the fight for Mosul and many
women still in the same situation you
were in do you have hope for those that
are still in Iraq at the moment yes we
have hope we cannot stop hoping we are
hopeful that the captives will be
liberated and freed yes we look forward
to that day when - is will be held
accountable for the crimes and I hope
that the captives will be liberated and
free inshallah of Joan yeah a little
[ __ ]
Venezuela mashallah for me it is not
whether we have hope or not we should
combat - we should force the interaction
between - in Iraq and Syria then - will
be diminished as a force and - we'll
lose ground and then we will liberate
the girls and women in an easier way so
it is not a question of hope we have to
combat - so we can liberate everybody -
how about you what I would like to know
at the end is a prize like the Sakharov
Prize what does it mean to you you know
does it have do you think it will can
really change things
taina hi J's Annie the surprise is very
important for us for all of us not only
for me and Nadia know it is very
important for all the women that are
tortured or that are victims of - the
world will see will hear our voice will
listen to our story and will take steps
to defend us you should assert now yes
Tara via Sakharov Shakira penis button
ovens Agora fries is very important for
us for us victims it is a huge support
from the European Union and for the
Yazidi community but the Sakharov Prize
will not stop - the European Union
should combat - should hold -
accountable should bring peace and
stability to stop this extremist
ideology what we do not want is the
re-emergence of this ideology we do not
want these crimes to be committed again
yes the prize is the men's to
disseminate our voice because Dyess
changed our status not as women but as
captives
but Sakharov brought dignity to us and
honor to us Sakharov vagina shot of
vodka remote Regina
Nadia Murad Lamia aji Bashar thank you
very much for finding the time to
talking to me and I wish you well all
the strength and and and all the good
things in the future